more and more companies are looking to
unlock business insights from their data
but it can be hard to scale ibly ingest
store and analyze that data as it
rapidly grows Google's enterprise data
warehouse bigquery was designed to make
large-scale data analysis accessible to
everyone in this series will show you
how big we can help you get valuable
insights from your data with ease ask
questions and get answers on bigquery
spotlight
[Music]
if you're a developer data analyst or
just about anyone else you're probably
working with data if your business has
small amounts of data you might be able
to store it in a spreadsheet but as your
amount of data grows to gigabytes
terabytes or even petabytes you start to
need a more efficient system like a data
warehouse that's because all that data
isn't very useful unless you have a way
to analyze it traditionally larger sets
of data means longer times between
asking your questions and getting
answers have you ever needed to wait
hours or days for an analytics report to
be run bigquery was designed to handle
massive amounts of data such as log data
from thousands of retail systems or IOT
data from millions of vehicles sensors
across the globe it's a fully managed
and serviced data warehouse which
empowers you to focus on analytics
instead of managing infrastructure by
design bigquery helps you avoid the data
silo problem which happens when you have
individual teams in your company having
their own independent data Mart's this
can create significant friction between
analyzing data across teams and cause
challenges with data version control
thanks to the integration with Google
clouds native Identity and Access
Management you can assign read or write
permissions to specific users groups or
projects and keep your sensitive data
secure all while still collaborating
across teams working with data and
bigquery
involves three primary parts storage
ingestion and querying Google handles
running everything else bigquery is a
fully managed service which means you
don't need a setup or install anything
and you don't require a database
administrator you can simply log into
your Google cloud project from a browser
and get started first let's talk about
bigquery storage data is stored in a
structured table which means that you
can use standard sequel for easy
querying and data analysis for example
let's say that you have some data that
represents the sales for each of your
stores in the last year you could
probably use a smaller database for that
but what if you have thousands of stores
and what if you want revenue broken up
by product SKU or by region per time
period bigquery is perfect for big data
we manage all that storage and the
scaling operations automatically for you
of course storing the data doesn't
matter if you can't get into bigquery in
the first place
thankfully there are lots of ways to do
that as bigquery is integrated with the
rest of the data analytics platform from
Google you can upload data from cloud
storage and just streaming data from
cloud dataflow build an ETL pipeline
using cloud data fusion import data from
a variety of file formats or use a
combination of all of these we'll go
over these and more in future episodes
so that you can decide which setup is
right for your data sets once your data
is in bigquery you're ready to start
answering those questions bigquery
supports the same structured query
language or sequel that you may be
familiar with if you worked with ANSI
compliant relational databases in the
past we'll go over multiple ways to work
with data and bigquery so that you can
choose what's best for your use case
plus you'll be able to share access with
other users so that they can drive
insights from your data to want to skip
straight to analyzing some data you can
bypass the ingestion and storage steps
by analyzing the bigquery public data
sets these are third-party data sets
which have been made public for anyone
to query against Google handles all of
the storage so that you can focus on
figuring out answers to questions like
how does the weather in New York City
affect demand for taxi cabs in this
series we'll walk you through the
play-by-play some of the most common
tasks in bigquery and share some best
practices to help you up your game but
if you want to get started right now
click on the link below and start with
the bigquery sandbox the sandbox gives
you a free environment to try out
bigquery and you can get started by
analyzing public datasets immediately
look out for our next episode of bakery
spotlight and remember stay curious
[Music]
you